Okay. So, welcome to lecture number four
of the course. Today is in a fully
online mode.
uh let's start with what we have been
trying to do for the last three lectures
which is that we want to deal with pees
and we either want to solve them or
learn them mean there is no distinction
between the two at the moment but you'll
see that there will be distinction and
we're going to do that using deep
neuronet networks so this is the sort of
light motif for the course now in the
first in the lecture last week what we
studied are pins of physics informed
neural networks.
So physics informed neural networks
and these algorithms
to
solve PDS directly using neural
networks, right? So we were able to use
pins and solve the PDS. So this was sort
of the basic logic. So let me remind you
of what pins are so that we can do more
work with them.
So if you recall, let's consider an
abstract PD because uh instead of
looking at the heat equation or the
Navia Stokes equation or posance
equation, we can as well look at an
abstract PD. Let me change the color. So
this is uh this guy here. So d of u= f.
Now d can be some nonlinear differential
operator in general. But uh each time
I'm saying this, you can think of the
heat equation. So ut minus llassian of u
equals to x and in this formulation what
I've done is that I have sort of
silenced out um the boundary and the
initial conditions I've said that
they're somehow implicitly assumed. So
for instance you on the boundary equals
to zero something like this okay just to
sort of u reduce the amount of notation
that one has to look at. So this is the
basic basic idea here. So now we have a
PD we have solution we have the
conditions given right the initial and
boundary conditions and we have a
solution and the solution is given by
the function U. Similarly what we're
going to do is we're going to
approximate it with neural networks. So
if you recall neural networks are
nothing but parametric functions E of
the where theta are the weights and
biases of the neural network. So this is
a deep neuron network and the idea is
that so this is some space in which it
belongs to and the idea is that we are
going to find theta such that u theta
the new network the realization behind
these parameters is going to match the
or going to be close to the solution of
the PD in some suitable sense right so
this is the basic basic idea and since
we don't have access to the solutions of
the PD directly we use the PD residual
Right? So this is the key idea behind
neural networks that at every point in
spacetime in principle we can evaluate
the PD residual. Now the PD residual is
simply you take the PD here and you just
try to sort of um plug it into the the
neural network is plugged into this form
of the PD. So you take u of theta you
take it at any point y you compute the
differential operator d and the right
hand side f and then see what the error
is or what the residual is if it's an
exact solution then this will be zero at
every point right so that would that's
definition of an exact solution of pd
but this is not uh the exact solution so
there will be some error so what we're
going to do is to sum up or integrate
this error across all points
And this is what is essentially the sort
of average residual or residual
and this is the quantity that we are
going to minimize. So we don't need data
per se but we need explicit information
about the PTE so that we can plug in the
residual but uh if you recall this is a
integral right so integrals cannot be
evaluated by hand we need to evaluate
them using quadriure rules and uh to do
so I need a set of quadriure points not
the whole domain which is a continuous
object but I need a set of quadriure
points which I denote by yi this could
be any quadure points this could be
random points or quasi [clears throat]
Monte Carlo or whatever Gaus points,
Gaus Newton, Gaus Lejantra points, Gaus
Lag points, Hammit, whatever. There are
tons and tons of quarter rules and each
of these quarter rules comes just with a
weight wi each uh the individual point
comes with a particular weight and this
integral here is replaced by this sum
here. Right? So if you have Monte Carlo
for instance, the weight is just 1 / n
for each point. And this gives you a
form of the residual that is computable
that we can evaluate on a computer
because all that you have to do is to
look at look up the point compute the
residual by using automatic
differentiation back propagation
whatever you call it efficiently then um
weigh it with this weight and then you
optimize this loss function. So instead
of having a supervised loss, you can
think of this as being a unsupervised
loss. So that is the pins algorithm and
I think on Monday Suzang covered the
algorithmic aspects. So it ends up being
u very high dimensional. The dimension
depends on the number of parameters that
you have in the neuron network. It could
be thousand or a few hundreds to a few
thousands to a million or whatever. And
then of course needless to say this is a
non-convex loss function. and then we
can optimize it for instance with Adam
or PFGS or whatever. Right? So this is
sort of the algorithm. You choose your
quarter points then you compute the
residuals at those quarter points
pointwise. So you do this weigh them
using a quadriure rule and then use your
standard uh neural network non-convex
optimization techniques optimization
algorithms to be able to evaluate that.
So this is a rather straightforward
procedure and in the last lecture what I
showed
what I showed you are different
algorithmic realizations or different
examples of this. So for instance for
the heat equation which I wrote down in
the last lecture in the last uh slide
you could see that this does a very very
good job and we could even solve very
very high dimensional problems 100
dimensions thousand dimensions whatever
and [snorts] this was done with a low
amount of error in particular because
the error was not growing quadrat not
growing exponentially we did not have a
curse of dimensionality so this was the
good news with these methods we also
could do parametric pds so this is where
data comes in. So PD plus data
and for instance we had the KDV equation
which is given by this nonlinear
equation here. It models dispersive
waves uh dispersive waves solids for
instance. And then we saw that we could
parameterize the initial conditions
given by this formula here and we could
compute the solution very easily. And
the last example which is also PDS plus
data data plus physics as I write here
were inverse problems of different types
parameter identification and this sort
of unique continuation problem. So this
was from Stokes if you recall from the
last lecture and we saw that even though
only measurements of the velocity were
given. So this was velocity we could
still evaluate pressure. So this the
pressure over the whole field with some
low error. It was like 3.8% 8% or 3% or
something. So from these examples, it
seemed like that uh pins they work very
well, right? So this sort of and there
as I as I said there are at least tens
of thousands of papers that have been
written on pins in the last let's say 3
4 years. So it's sort of incumbent upon
us to understand why and when do pins
work, right? And this will be sort of
the main objective of my lecture today
to try to elucidate for you to explain
to you the mechanisms by which this
construction works why it should work
why it shouldn't work and also to
identify failure modes and uh you'll see
that there is an interesting story that
comes out okay so today since we are on
a fully online mode I encourage people
to ask me questions over zoom and just
use the chat and then or you can also
unmute yourself and ask questions that's
also completely fine. So now the
rationale for the lecture is very clear.
This scene is set and then we go and we
try to see and explore why pins work or
when do they work and so on. So let me
try to explain what goes on and I will
explain it. Uh there's a lot of math
here and the audience is mixed. So I'm
not going to go into some detailed
calculations but I'll try to convey the
key ideas to you and this would be sort
of the objective. So again let's take
the abstract PD. So whenever I write
down this abstract PD you can the heat
equation.
>> Uh do you want to ask me a question
otherwise can you please mute yourself?
Yeah. Okay. No no no worries. So now
let's uh consider the abstract PD. We
think of the heat equation and the idea
is that we want to approximate it with
neuronet networks right so we are of
course going to have some error some
mismatch it won't be the exact solution
and the mismatch is given by what is
called the total error so this is uh
this uh notation here e of theta so u
theta is my neural network u is my exact
solution of the pd assume that it exists
it has nice properties nice behavior and
then I measure the mismatch in some norm
in some p norm right because it is
defined on the domain perhaps it's worth
writing this down so that uh there's no
confusion let's say that the domain is d
this could be space time not just space
so this is u of y - u theta of y
^ p d y over 1 / p so this is the px
norm right so you take at every point u
let's see you take at every point the
exact solution you subtract it find the
from the approximate solution. Take a
norm over the entire domain and then
this is your exact solution and we want
this to be as low as possible. Right? So
this would be our objective that the
total error is made as small as
possible. But the point about so in
supervised learning this would have been
fine because this would be my samples my
training examples and this would be my
predictions of the neuronet network and
you try to measure the difference
between them. This would be a problem in
sort of conventional learning theory. We
will we will discuss that in the coming
lectures. But of course uh remember that
the whole point the whole uh rationale
behind pins is the fact that we don't
have measurements. We don't have this
exact uh any information about in
particular about the exact solution
right we don't know may not have access
to samples from the exact solution and
we have to indirectly do the
approximation. So what do we do instead
as I said repeatedly in the last lecture
and earlier today we have to use the PD
residual. So the PD residual is given by
this expression here that you take the
you you sort of evaluate the neural
network on the PE and then you see how
big that is. But of course in practice
so this PD residual now just for
notational purposes I'm going to denote
by this EG. Okay, this simply means the
PD residual norm. Okay, so this is this
not pointwise but it's normed. But in
practice we know that this is an
integral. We cannot compute this
integral. So we stick to this what is
called the training error. So this is
just the loss function norm. Okay. So
now what is what do we have? So this is
the object that we can minimize. So this
is our target. You can also think of it
as a target.
And our hope is that we can minimize
this guy. So we can take u of t and make
it small. Okay, I'll write it in the
next page. So this can be made small.
This is by neural network training.
Right? So this is objective. We can try
to make this small. Now the the the
trick or perhaps the route to to working
here is that you make this training
error small and somehow by making this
training error small, we can make the
total residual small. Remember that this
is just a sum. This is an integral. So
if you make the sum small, we try to
make the integral small. So that will
mean that we'll have a small PD
residual.
And if you have a small PD residual,
that's not enough because my objective
is not to have a small PD residual. But
I know that when the PD residual is
zero, I have the exact solution. The
question is does a small PD residual
which we can potentially target through
the training error does this imply the a
small total error right so this is the
route in which we are going to go uh
what is in our hands potentially is to
make the training error small will that
imply that the residual is small and
will a small residual imply that the
exact solution or the difference to the
exact solution is uh small so that is
the only route that we have practically
And hopefully pins allow us to realize
this route. So is this uh is this clear?
So perhaps it's worth um sort of
repeating it because this is an
important point. So what what are we
trying to say summarizing? So we want a
small so target our target is a small
training error.
Small training error
right? So this is the only thing that we
can target. I think I called it as E T.
So E T of theta is small. So it's less
than some epsilon, right? So this is or
perhaps what is better is to say that
this is
behaves like epsilon something like
this. But from this we want to imply
that uh we have a small residual
small PD residual.
[snorts]
So the notation was eg eg of theta will
be of the order of epsilon. So if you
can ensure that there is a small
residual then the next part which is of
course is that this is small total error
small total error. So this is e right
this is without any suffix this is so
this is the route that we are going to
adopt. So hopefully we have uh the
ability to make this small and then
automatically this should become small
and automatically this should become
small because we we will never have
access to the residual per se because we
only have realizations in terms of the
training error and we'll never have
access to the exact solution. So the
only logical route that we can we can go
through is through this route right and
this is sort of uh the mechanism by
which pins could work and in fact this
is where what I have written down here
in some let's [snorts] say in some
notation here. So the first question of
course uh remember that this is this is
the route that can we make the training
error small from there can we ensure
that the residual is small and from
there we can can we ensure that the
total error is small right so this is
the mechanism it is repeated here for
pedagogical purposes. So our first
objective or the only objective that we
can have is to see if our training error
is going to be small right can it be
made small or not. So this will be a key
question and then training loss or
training error does it imply that there
is a small pin residual. So this is this
part here. So from here to here can no
the other way around from here to here
can we go and this is uh possible of
course provided that we have bounds or
we have some guarantees or some
relationship which says that the
residual which is given by eg is bounded
in terms of training error and the
number of points right so because you
have a number of quarter points so the
idea is that the sum starts
approximating an integral when the
number of points at which the sum is
taken goes to infinity. So this is
written by this relationship here. So as
the number of points goes to infinity,
we would expect that this error here,
this residual is as close to the
training error as possible. So this is
an expectation. This is a question,
right? So this is important to remember
here. And finally, the final piece of
the puzzle is that if this guy is small,
the PD residual, not the training error,
but the PD residual, can we imply that
the total error is small? And this is
possible if we have a bound which goes
like this. Right? So these are some
concrete realizations of what I just
said. Small training error here. This
will imply that the total uh the
residual is going to be small when the
number of points is large. So this is if
n is large, right? Because then this
term goes to zero. This is as close to
the training error and the training
error is epsilon. So this guy also
becomes epsilon. And finally, if this
guy is epsilon, the PD residual, then of
course the total error is of the order
of epsilon. So these estimates are just
a concrete realization of what I just
said. But the intuitive mechanism is
very very clear that the only route is
through this diagram, this flowchart
that I've just sketched here. Okay. So
is the strategy clear? Is there any
question? You can also ask over zoom or
uh you can also sort of unmute yourself.
This is this is the crux of today's
lecture right to see that these um sort
of estimates or these mechanisms can be
realized in practice.
No questions. Okay fine let's uh let's
proceed. So let's see whether this can
be answered.
So it turns out that uh I will take it
step by step. Right. So there are three
three steps here. So what I'm going to
do is I'll start in the reverse order
since this is perhaps a little bit
chronological also. So first what I'm
going to do is to look at this question.
So Q1 so Q1 so that is uh does a small
residual imply a small total error? Then
I'm going to answer this question. Does
a small training error imply a small
residual? And finally I'm going to
answer this question which is does uh a
small can a small training error be
reached? Right? So even though the
flowchart goes this way my development
today will go the other way around.
Okay. So this would be the rough idea.
So let us start uh trying to understand
this. So remember the question is if the
residual is small can we have bounds on
the total error. So if the small
residual should imply small total error.
Okay. So this is the this is the
direction that we would like to explore
and this was first explored actually by
me some years ago because uh this entire
program was sketched out by me more or
less very quickly after the the paper
itself was published in 2021.
But uh this is very quickly after pins
started getting popularity and I wanted
to understand why they might work and
this is the route that I came up with
together with Roberto Mono former PhD
student of mine. So what do we do there?
So remember what is our objective?
Objective is
small residual
residual. So this is given by EG. Does
it imply small error
E? Now this has nothing to do with the
neural networks because it does not even
you can have anything here you know you
can have any kind of approximate
solution. It depends more on the
structure of the PTE than on the neural
network. So what we came up with in this
uh argument [snorts] and other people
have developed that further is to
provide some conditions on your
underlying PD on your underlying physics
such that this is true and this
condition you can call it stability but
we prefer the word coercivity. This is
uh there is there is some there is some
rationale behind the terminology but
it's not not important. Okay. So what we
said is the following. So you consider a
PD D of U equals to F. So this is your
abstract PTE and now you consider two
different possible solutions. So you
have U and U bar. Of course when you
plug U into the PD you get a F. You plug
U bar into the PD you get a different
solution. D of U bar equals to F bar.
Right? So these are two different
solutions in the PD for you can imagine
that F and F bar are somehow close to
each other. Right? So what coercivity is
is a statement of some sort of stability
for the PD. So it says that uh the
difference between this u and u bar
measured in some norm p here is given in
terms of the difference in the right
hand sides because this guy is nothing
but fbar and this guy is f. So if you
change so f and f bar are the inputs to
the pd right so they are the inputs to
the pd. So if you change the input
slightly uh it says that the solution
changes slightly or slightly is measured
in terms of this constants here which
can be large but there's a proportionate
change right so what this is uh this
saying is that your system which is
governed by PT has a pro has some
stability so you can think of it as
stability it's not strictly stability
but uh it's it's a good way it's a good
heristic to think about so the [snorts]
idea is that you make a small change in
the inputs to the PD which is the right
hand side given by this terms here then
there is a proportionately small change
of the outputs to the PD okay so this is
roughly the idea of uh residuals or idea
of coivity now many many different PDEs
of course satisfy this so why does this
have anything to do with small residuals
and so on right so let's try to see that
actually this is three lines so it's
very easy to explain so remember my
objective is to make the total error as
small as possible. So if I write down
the total error, it is a neural network
minus the exact solution nor right. So
now remember that uh this is coercivity.
So coercivity is given by this statement
here. So all that I do is I take my u
bar equals to u theta. So if I take my u
bar equals to u theta plug out this here
so I get this constant uh which depends
on the solution itself because it's in
general nonlinear then you have this
statement here so this is the statement
of coercivity so it says that the
outputs to the PTE are given in terms of
the inputs or the right hand side okay
that's fine but remember that d of u
equals to f right so d of u I I've made
a mistake here d of u equals to F. So
this gets substituted here. No problems.
This now is the interesting object. As I
said, D of U equals to F. Now this here
is the interesting object because this
is precisely your residual, right? So
this is the residual
which is given by your E of G. Okay. So
what have we shown here that the total
error E of theta is related to the
residual EG of theta. Okay. And it's
related in terms of these constants
here. So in particular if this guy is
zero, this guy will also be zero which
is which is rather straightforward. But
what is much more important is that this
if the residual is going to be small and
depending on how this quantities behave
then this uh also going to be small,
right? So remember what was our
objective? Objective was to show that a
small residual implies a small total
error. And this is precisely one of the
mechanisms. Remember that this is a
sufficient condition. It's by no mean
necessary. So what happens is that if
you have this coercivity condition then
we what we have shown through this very
very simple calculation is that a small
residual automatically implies a small
total error. So one part of our program
is achieved. So if you can make the
residual small and as long as the PD is
coercive and this has to be checked on a
caseby case basis for different PTEES
you have to check this then uh the total
error is going to be small so that's
that's quite a statement right it's
quite an important statement good so
that more or less answers our first
question that we raised that can a small
residual imply a small error yes Bob go
ahead
>> um I have a question depending uh on See
like what is the is there any
restrictions on the
>> Oh yes oh yes there are lots there are
it's a very good question Bob there are
many many restrictions we are going to
look at this C in some detail uh in the
next 15 minutes or so so we'll have
different examples of this C and you
will see that uh this C can blow up so
the constant can become infinite and
then this uh bound is useless right
>> the bound is only useful when uh C this
C is a good quantity Right? So just
imagine if the C is of order of one then
it's fine. So if the error is the
residual is 1% my error is 1%. Perfect.
But just imagine if the uh C is 100 can
happen and you'll see it will happen.
Then if my residual is 1% my error will
be 100%. And it's not going to be very
very useful. But you picked the right
question here because it depends very
much on the nature of this C. But we are
going to we are going to explore this in
some detail. Thank you.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Uh then there's a question from Luca.
How do we check that the PD is squares
if this is a very very good question
Luca? This is uh this is PTE theory,
right? I mean someone has to do this.
Someone who knows about PDEs has to do
this calculation and you'll see some
examples in a in a second. Each of this
is a paper, right? So because it's it's
not so straightforward to check this. It
depends on understanding PDS, right? So
this is uh so this is this is a part of
that. Okay. So this question and we will
we'll explore the constant we'll explore
some specific samples in a bit but at
least the the overall trend is is very
clear. Good. So then uh comes the
perhaps the easier one. So this is one
part of this. Remember that I keep on
going back to this. So this one we have
answered now right? So we say that if it
is coercive
then uh a small residual automatically
implies a implies a small uh error. But
what about this question which says that
does a small training error imply a
small residual right because we only can
target the training error. As some of
you might have suspected this is perhaps
the easiest question. Why is that? So
now what is the aim? Aim is
small training error. small training
error
should imply small residual because then
if the residual is small and the PD is
coercive we know that it is small total
error right so this is the mechanism
here so let us recall so what is the PD
residual it's given by this quantity the
this quantity here norm so it is this
integral here right so this is this is
the integral but remember that in
practice we only have access to the
training error but This training error
is nothing but a quadriure
approximation. Right? So as you can see
this guy approximates this guy. This is
a sum. This is an integral. But as we
know that we take more and more points
or more and more terms in the sum more
and more summons as they're called. Then
this in this quadriure or this sum is
going to approximate the integral. And
it depends on the smoothness of the
function. It depends on what kind of
quadricure rule that we're choosing. But
we can do it for instance Monte Carlo
random points. uh the the the rate of
convergence is going to be of the order
of 1 / the square root of n. For some
other points, it would be higher. This
is a this is a minimum you can do,
right? So and it's dimension independent
and so on. So for random points, you can
essentially guarantee that rather easily
in some probabilistic sense because
everything is random. But in general,
these are quarter approximations. So
there's a whole objective here which
means that uh essentially EG minus ET
is given by this uh constant here.
So this quadriure it depends on this uh
E theta I don't know where does a theta
star come in it's just a theta
um okay at least here it's just a theta
so this is a constant which depends on
the smoothness of the function. So for
instance if it is Monte Carlo this will
be like the variance right so this is uh
you can you can compute and then this
alpha is the rate of convergence okay
alpha is the rate of convergence and we
are taking we're dividing over a 1 / b
so alpha is equal to a half for instance
for Monte Carlo for other quadriure it
could be one it could be two depending
on what we are looking at it could even
be 10 if it's a smooth function so this
in a way guarantees because all that you
have to do is to take uh n to be large
and if you take n to be large then what
happens is that this term goes to zero
and then the uh residual becomes as
close to the training error as possible.
So this is just a quadriure assumption
approximation essentially. So this is
the easy bit that you can just
approximate using quades. So now uh are
there any questions about this? This is
this should be crystal clear right
because we have integrals we have
quadures and all that we're going to say
is that as the number of points
increases the quarter comes as close as
possible to the integral. So this
question here so if you go back to my
flowchart this is answered. So this is
just quarter check
quarter
and this question Q3 can we make the
training error small will be the crux of
the matter and this we'll come to after
the break. So now by taking these two
questions we have answered at least
something means uh we have answered that
if the residual is small the total error
is small provided that the BD is coisive
and if the trainer training error is
small the residual is small. So this is
more or less quadrice. So any any
function this is any residual this is
going to be true for instance by using
Monte Carlo. But we can use high auto
quadatures and get a faster convergence
a faster decay of the error. So
essentially summing up uh as we did in
this paper some years ago. So what we
have to check for a given PD and this
was one of the questions I think Luca
asked is that uh you have to check that
it is coercive. So that this is
satisfied. You also have to check that
uh you have this quadriure properties.
So in particular you have to compute
what these constants are. So again I
have a star here that I should remove.
But and then you have to compute uh
these these constants right because the
everything lies in these constants. If
these constants are like order one
you're good. But if these constants are
like a order of thousand, then the fact
that you have a small training error
does not necessarily imply that you have
a small uh you will probably have a
large bound here. Similarly here, right?
So it's also important. So there is a
program here. So given a PD uh you have
to find out whether this coercivity
holds and what are the constants for the
quarter approximation and then you can
answer at least some question which is
small training error
small training error implies
small
total error.
So this is the question that we have
answered provided that these sub points
can be answered. Okay. So now let's try
to look at some examples just to
illustrate what's going on. Uh the first
example is a heat equation essentially
but a sort of a more bigger
generalization of heat equation. This is
what are called colmogore of PDS. Some
people also call them as drift diffusion
equations or advection diffusion
equations.
Drift diffusion equations.
I've written them in sort of a
complicated notation but uh you can
think of the heat equation. So if you
take this drift to be equal to zero and
if you can take these guys to be the
identity matrix components of the
identity matrix you precisely get the
heat equation because this is nothing
but the lelassian operator right so it's
identity matrix this will be the
llashian operator and this is UT so this
is a heat equation but uh this this is
important in finance it's important in
stoastic processes because the if you
have a stoastic differential equation
for those who know the distribution
function it obeys a cologor of partial
differential equation. So this is sort
of the the genesis of it. But you can
think of it essentially as a heat
equation plus some transport plus some
diffusion. And uh in in option pricing
you have the black shaws equation. I
think I started out with this in the
very first lecture. And then you have
some non-trivial drift and you have some
non-trivial diffusion. Not just identity
non-trivial diffusion. And the point
about this cologor pds is that they can
be very high dimensional. So now do they
satisfy these conditions? Are they are
they coercive and so on? These are
linear equations. So actually for linear
equations the good thing is that they
are more or less always stable. Okay. So
the first two points are not important
by the way. This was done by me and a
student of mine Tim Direct some years
ago. U and then what do we show? because
in this case it's a linear PD. These are
linear PDS. So essentially maybe it's
worth doing a simple calculation
somewhere just to show that in linear
PDS this is uh less of a problem. So
what is a linear PD? In a linear PD you
have d of u equals to f. So this a
linear this is linear
and d of u bar equal to f. Okay. So now
you subtract the two d of u minus d of u
bar equals to f minus f bar. You want to
compare the two right? You want to
compare [clears throat] cohivity is if
you change the inputs f and f bar how or
f2 f rather how does the output u to u
bar change but this is linear. So what
happens here is that this becomes u
minus u bar. Right? This is linearity is
equal to f minus f bar. Okay. So now all
that you have to do is uh invert d.
So inversion is not that easy but if it
can be done then u - u bar is equal to t
inverse of f minus f bar.
Okay so the linear operator like if you
think of the lelassian this will be the
negative llassian the inverse llassian.
Now you take a norm here u - u bar is
equal to norm of d inverse of f - f bar
and this is those who know this norms
they behave also matrix norms right
matrix norms have the same behavior as
do operator norms. So this is f inverse
f minus f bar which is nothing but uh d
inverse
of d of u minus d of u bar. So this is
coercivity for linear problems
and the constant is explicitly given by
the norm of the inverse of the linear
operator. So this is the this is the key
quantity. It is independent of the of
the solution itself. Right? So in for
nonlinear problems you cannot say that
this depends on the on the solutions and
the approximations but for linear
problems they are independent of that.
Okay. So these are very very
straightforward calculations that one
can do. So if your linear operator is
invertible and it has a bounded inverse
then you are coercive. This is where the
word coercivity actually comes from. So
this is essentially leading to the
stability of the PT because for the heat
equation and for heat like equations you
can show by very it's not
straightforward. It will take one
lecture for me to do the entire math but
you can essentially follow that process
make it rigorous and you come up with a
bound like this that it depends on the
inte uh in the interior residual and the
boundary residual which I didn't really
write down here and then you get a
constant which is independent okay and
this constant depends purely on the PTE
and it's essentially order one okay
that's the that's the whole point and
then quadriure you can do some Monte
Carlo and ultimately you end up with
something which is independent of the
coercive dimension. So this tells you
small residual so these are small
residuals implies small error. This can
be done rigorously for the heat equation
and small training error plus large
number of points. So this is u Monte
Carlo essentially with some logarithmic
corrections this uh some concentration
inequalities then you get a small
generalization error. So what this
calculation show you is that as long as
the training error is small, you can
make the residual small this is this
bound here. If you have a large number
of points and if the residual is small,
the total error is small which is given
by this relationship here. So this can
be done and I don't know how well you
can see this but this is some
calculations shown in practice. So let's
see what we can. So we have a actually a
computable bound right the computable
bound is given by these quantities and
we try to verify it for the heat
equation. So this is the number of
quarter points. This is in this
direction. This is the error.
Uh the let me I I don't see it very well
but the green is I think the so the red
is the residual I think or maybe it's
the total error. So the red is the total
error. there's some training error which
are sitting close to each other. So the
training error and the total error are
very very close to each other which
shows that there is perfect
generalization and then there's a
computable bound. The computable bound
has constants and so on. So it's not
sharp but it behaves like this. So as
the number of training points goes it uh
reduces as does the total error. There
is a gap between them. Right? This is
not a sharp sharp bound. It's like three
orders of magnitude in this particular
case. But in machine learning having a
bound which is like two to three orders
of magnitude is a big achievement
because if you look at theory for
machine learning like for classification
for segmentation and so on this is 30
orders of magnitude. So we were very
happy that we were able to get something
which was that close. Uh this is how the
training error behaves. These are for
different kinds of neural networks.
Right? So this is how the training error
behaves. This is how the total error
behaves. Right? So there's some wrong
notation here. This is the total error.
You can clearly see the trend right? So
you have the trend line which is here.
So what does it mean that small training
error implies small total error right?
Sometimes what happens is that you can
have a small total error but a large
training error but never the other way
around. If the training error is large
the total error is also large. Okay. So
this just shows that these are not just
some vacuous bounds but they are also
sort of seen in practice. So this is
this this is a good thing.
Good. So this was one example. Uh let's
see how much of time we have. So what I
suggest now is that uh we can take a
little break. Uh maybe we come back in
15 minutes around uh 10 past 15 even 10
12. Uh let's take a 15 minute break and
then from there we can we can sort of do
more examples. Okay. So because the next
one is probably Navia Stokes. Okay. Let
me let me finish with this one. So this
is another numerical result. So this was
for the heat equation. This results here
are the heat equation
[snorts]
and this is for uh not just the heat
equation but also black shaws. You can
see similar behavior that uh I think you
have already seen this and the last one
was some hon. So similar to black shles
but a system of equations again the same
similar kind of behavior. Okay. So my
suggestion is that we take a little
break now. We we meet at quarter past
and uh then we continue doing some more
examples and seeing whether this theory
works that small training error implies
a small total error here. It's very very
clear that that is the case. Right? So
we we we did hit that theory uh
perfectly in this particular example.
Okay. So with that let me sort of pause
the recording.
Okay. Okay. So during the break there
was a question by Oliver which said
about the choice of quadature points. So
do we change them per epoch or do we
keep the fixed set of quarter points?
Actually I had sort of covered that
question maybe last lecture and the
point is that this corresponds to either
doing a full batch gradient descent or
doing a mini batch gradient descent.
Both options are fine.
uh there doesn't seem to be generally
people use full batch gradient descent
but one can use mini batch gradient
descent in the context of pins it's not
very common because the neural networks
are relatively smaller and there are
other problems as you will see later
today but both of them are but perfectly
viable options okay so let us continue
with the plan that we have which is that
can we show that a small training error
implies a small residual and does a
small residual imply a small total error
The second example that I chose, you can
do this for many many PTEs and other
people have also done that. But the
second example that I chose is a Navia
Stokes equation. This is a particularly
important one as we all know.
So Navia Stokes equation Navia Stokes
equation are given by this relationship
here. It's a system of equations. It's
no longer a scalar equation. Right? Uh
you also have the divergence constraint
uh due to incompressibility.
[snorts] And there was uh some theory
this was worked out in this paper some
years ago and the idea was that again
it's PD theory right so there is you
have to you have to use some knowledge
about the Navia Stokes equations which
we successfully did and we were able to
show that uh this is a nonlinear
equation now right so you cannot expect
that uh that the solution that this
cohivity is independent of the solution
it isn't right so if you take the L2
norm then you can compare the exact
exact solution and the approximate
solution in terms of the different
components of the residual. So this is
the residual of the divergence. There is
a bad uh factor here square root which
tells us that we really have to make the
divergence as small as possible. The
same thing with the boundary conditions.
Uh then you have the initial conditions
and then we have the interior terms
which is the velocity residual. And here
the main difference from the last time
is you have a bound like this. But the
bound now depends very much on the
solution of the PD. In particular, it
does not depend on the solution per se,
but it depends on its curl. Now for
those who know fluid dynamics, the curl
of the velocity field has a spec special
physical interpretation. It is what is
called the vorticity. So vorticity is
essentially if you have vortices, how
strong the vortex is, how powerful it
is, how how integrated or how compact it
is. This is all measured by the
vorticity. So what it tells us, what
this estimate tells us is that as long
as the vorticity of the flow is under
control and this is a very very sort of
key quantity, then we can show that
small residuals which is given here
implies small training errors. And
similarly for the quarter bounds this is
uh straightforward again if the function
the underlying function the solution is
smooth then you can you can apply
different kind of quarter rules and you
get a relationship like this which says
that if the training error is small and
you have large number of points then the
total error is going to be the the
residual is going to be small which will
automatically imply through this bound
that the total error is going to be
small. So you can even work this out for
a nonlinear equation like the Navia
Stokes equations and you see that in
practice. If you remember this was a
vortex which was moving with the flow
something like this. So this is the
evolution of the flow. This is the exact
solution. This is the pin
and we were able to show in this case
also we were able to compute the bounds.
Let me try to expand this. So the
training error. So this is the number of
points. So we were able to train better
as there were more number of points. So
you can see that the training error was
a very small quantity. It was somewhere
here. Now in this particular case the
total error was also a small quantity.
It was like 1% here. So small training
error implies small total error as the
estimates suggest. And we also have this
bound right. So this bound uh this is
the bound that is there. It showed us
that uh there is some relationship
between the two and the bound also went
down as the number of points increased
right and as the uh as the total error
became smaller and here the the
difference was much more like a factor
of 20. So this was this was quite
satisfactory in some sense. So this is
good news right that we have a theory
which tries to explain that if you have
a small training error the total error
is going to be small and it seems to be
borne out by practical examples but this
theory also tells us some caveats some
warning signs and the warning sign is
given precisely by this quantity here.
So now in this case the vorticity
remains the same right because it's just
a vortex which is being affected out. So
we expect good uh control on the
vorticity. But what if the vorticity
increases? Now here is a simple very
mild example of that. There are some
much more severe examples that you're
going to see later in the course
particularly in 3D. But even in 2D this
is a very simple example. So this is
actually the vorticity that we are
showing here. So this is the vorticity.
This is at tal. So this is exact this is
pin
and this is at t =0 and as t progresses
1 t equal to two something like this
right so as you can see the the
vorticity keeps on increasing I don't
know how well you can see the magnitude
but uh the the sort of the spread of the
vorticity it becomes so these zones they
become larger and larger right the
vorticity actually keeps on increasing
and you can see that the quality of
approximation the quality of the pin
solution also decreases. So here for
instance this exact solution very very
sort of clearly marked out vortex as you
can see here the pin is diffusing it
out. In fact the error I I remember the
numbers it goes like from 1% to like 5%.
So the error keeps on increasing as you
as time progresses simply because the
vorticity keeps on increasing. So in
this particular case we still have some
control on the vorticity but if we but
we see that there increases. So if you
have a case where the vortices are and
there are examples like that as you'll
see the the vortices the vorticity
becomes very large then of course the
error also becomes very large. So this
is uh this is a warning sign and this is
best sort of manifested this sort of
behavior for nonlinear equations of the
cohivity is best manifested for the
burgers equation. [snorts] Now this is
the burgers equation in 1D. Oh now of
course I used the wrong color. So this
is uh we are doing some computations in
1D. This is a multi-ders equation. So
you can do the same analysis. In fact in
our original paper we sort of carried
out the same analysis. We showed that
the total error is given in terms of the
training error the number of quarter
points and in terms of constants but
these constants depend on the gradient.
So in 1D there is no vorticity.
It [snorts] is simply the gradient of
the solution
because this is a nonlinear equation
again and in nonlinear equation
stability
depends very much on the solution that
you're trying to approximate. But here
one can even show that your gradient
because this is it it is due to
compression right. So you start with the
sine wave and it starts getting
compressed and compressed and compressed
and as this viscosity constant uh this
viscosity parameter goes to zero one can
show that the gradient will blow up.
You'll have what are called shock waves.
Okay. So shock waves are discontinuities
in the solution. These are physical
effects. You see them uh in your in your
tap for instance when you when you have
a sort of strong flow of water you get
what is called a hydraulic jump you know
different kinds of shock waves are there
sonic boom from an aircraft is a shock
wave and so on right so there are
different kinds of shock waves they're
there in nature and what the theory
predicts is that the approximation of
the pin will become worse and worse as
the viscosity goes to zero and as shocks
are formed and you see that so here for
instance is 10us3. So it's not yet a
shock wave and you still have a decent
approximation. So this is the
approximation uh here. Oh, sorry.
Maybe I can mark it. It's somewhere
here. This one. So it's a it's a it's a
decent approximation, right? But now
when the viscosity goes to zero, you see
that it completely collapses. So here
you can observe that there is uh the the
solution completely breaks down and
[snorts] you see it with respect to the
uh respect to the error. So as the
viscosity changes in this direction so
minus 3 the error was 1% then it became
11% then it became 23%. 23% is very very
higher right means you can in this
particular case 23% is unacceptably
higher. So this this tells us that uh
even the theory tells us when pins might
not work right in this particular case
they wouldn't work because um [snorts]
the solution becomes non-coercive in
some sense or unstable actually the same
thing uh if you have what are called
rarifactions. So there's the opposite of
shocks. Shocks are compression. Things
are pulled together something like this.
Whereas you can also pull things apart
because nonlinearity can go both ways.
So in this particular case the the
gradient does not blow up. It becomes
bounded. In fact it improves as you can
see you start off with something which
is uh let's say this example here you
start off with something which is
discontinuity but it becomes smooth as
time progresses. So in this particular
case uh as expected pins will do a good
approximation and in fact they do a good
approximation. the error does not blow
up as the viscosity blows up as the
viscosity becomes zero rather the error
actually improves. So this shows that uh
the theory is sort of spoton in this
[snorts] respect that it tells you that
even if the training error can be small
uh there can still be blowups in the
performance of the pen if the constants
blow up if it's not coercive and this is
rather sharp in that sense. So of course
there are ways to get around. So the the
the I I I will tell you a bottom line.
There are ways to sort of get around and
one way I don't have time to describe
this but if someone is interested is by
using what are called weak pins. So this
is weak pins where you don't use the
strong form of the residual because you
can imagine that when you have a
discontinuous function and you try to
plug it uh and your pin is going to
approximate a discontinuous function
right u is going to be discontinuity.
You saw that here u is going to be a
discontinuity and you plug it uh your
neural network is going to be a very
good approximation of the discontinuity.
So the gradient has to blow up right
otherwise it can't be a good
approximation of the discontinuity and
when you plug it in then you can imagine
that uh this uh the residual becomes
very very large and it becomes hard to
evaluate the residual. So there are only
two ways in which the neural network can
function. Either it can blow up or it
can smoothen things out. And this is
what it does. it sort of smoons the the
things out here as you can see. So this
is not surprising. So what we did in
weak pins is to not use the strong form
of the residual as it is written here
but to use a weak form of it. But this
is um I don't have the time to do this.
So if someone is interested you can look
at the paper. Okay. So let me just
summarize so that uh we have we have a
point somewhere. So essentially what we
showed is that for an abstract or a
generic PTE d of u equals f we have an
estimate on the total error which is
given by this uh quantity here. Okay. So
as long as this guy is small, as long as
this constant is order of one, the
number of points is large, n is large,
this quantity is order of one, then what
this theory tells us is that the pin is
going to be well behaved.
Now we already saw examples uh which
said that when this constant is uh going
to be badly behaved uh this coercivity
of the PD suffers then pins may not work
and we have already seen that right. So
failure modes. So this tells us
something about failure modes.
Failure modes
and so far we have identified one which
is that uh CPD
goes to infinity is large.
So these are precisely when the PD
itself becomes unstable then we are we
don't have a chance right uh in some
sense we it's not unstable per se but it
it does not satisfy the coivity
conditions then this this entire story
fails right the second one which you
have not understood at all in some sense
is what happens to the training error so
far the training error is a black box
okay and what I'm going to do in the
next half an hour is to try and uncover
what what happens to the training error
But before I move, is there any
question? Did everyone understand this
part about how we can actually show this
estimate for numerous PTEEs? But at the
same time, we should remember that this
constants can be ill behaved or the PTE
can be unstable and pins can fail as we
see from numerical experiments. Are
there any questions?
No. Okay. Fine. So let us try to
understand the training error. Now
training error is a beast altogether,
right? it's it's some sort of a black
box. It's not the easiest to unpeel and
I will be rather short because I want to
get into supervised learning very soon
uh in the next lecture. So let's see how
how much material I cover. But the
bottom line is what is important here
that as long as the training error is
small and as long as the PD is somehow
well behaved then pins should work as
they do right but once the PD starts
being ill behaved then there is a
problem. But what happens to the
training error? Now the first thing
about the training error that we have to
ensure is that it has to be small.
Right? So in principle it should be made
uh it should be possible to make it
small. It turns out that uh in principle
it is possible to make the training
error small. And why is that?
It's a very simple argument. So I try to
give it. So remember that we are still
with this PD d of u equals f. Uh the key
is if your solution is going to be
smooth. If it is not smooth, you have
already seen that there are issues,
right? But if the solution is smooth,
let's say it has several derivatives,
then what happens is that the residual
so if you look at the residual, the
residual is given by this quantity,
right? So this is given by this
quantity. But now this is nothing but um
d of u right because d of u equals to f.
So you can replace the f with the d of u
here. And then you can imagine that
these are differential operators, right?
Think of the lelassian. So in principle
I can sort of estimate them using what
are called soable spaces. For those who
don't know this is just using higher
derivatives, norms of higher
derivatives. So in principle the
residual if I knew the exact solution
then the residual can be estimated in
terms of some difference in the high
norms of the higher derivatives. Okay.
and the norm the s here the number of
derivatives it of course depends on the
on the number of derivatives in the
differential operator. Okay. So
essentially as long as we can show some
approximation if you remember that we
had shown that neural networks are
universal approximators in uh the space
of continuous functions for instance but
you can actually go further and you can
show that they are universal
approximators for these so-called sober
spaces. These are just high odd
derivatives. Uh don't let the jargon
scare you. So essentially for instance
in this paper and there are many others
what we showed is that uh you'll always
find neural networks which will
approximate a sufficiently smooth
function not just in terms of the
function itself but its first
derivative, its second derivative, its
third derivative, fourth derivative,
whatever order that you have. So you can
make as close approximations of smooth
functions as you want with neural
networks. So this is a slightly not
slightly but significantly finer
property than just saying that they
approximate continuous functions because
here they approximate not just a
function itself but its derivative it
second derivative third derivative
fourth derivative and so on. So what
will automatically imply is that as long
as the solution itself is smooth the
residual is going to be small. Okay so
you can show that the residual is going
to be small and this is a different
argument altogether. This is in the
other direction right? We want to argue
that the training error is going to be
small. So we cannot say that okay small
training error implies small residual
but here if the solution of the PD is
smooth then the pin residual can be made
small. But remember that the training
error and the residual are connected to
each other through the remember that we
had this quantity utus ug behaves like
this constant here. So we are sort of
reverting the estimate and we're saying
that as long as the solution of the
underlying BD is smooth my training
error in principle can be made as small
as possible because if you have
sufficient number of points my residual
is small because the of this nice
property that neural networks have and
then I can show that my total error not
the total error but the the training
error itself can be made very small okay
of the order of epsilon. So this is a
bare minimum. We need this, right?
Because if the training error cannot be
made small, what's the point of
targeting it? So we know that at least
this is uh this is satisfied. In other
words, the global minimum for my
optimization problem is well posed. This
is a small quantity, right? So this is a
small argument which tells you why that
is the case.
But the question that arises is is can
we reach it? Right? So this is what I
have asked here. Can the training
process reach the global minimum? So
summarizing what I show here is that the
global minimum of my loss function of my
training loss is small small global
minimum
at least. So there could be also some
local minimum which are small but we
know that there is the global minimum is
bound to be small right. The question is
can the training process ever reach this
global minimum. This is something that
uh that we will find out is not that
easy. But is this argument clear? So, so
in principle the training error can be
made small but in practice can it be
made small? That's what this argument
actually says. Okay. So let's try to
understand this and this was the last
part of the puzzle. Right. So in the
beginning we were able to show all these
things but we did not have a not just us
but the whole community did not have a
good understanding of whether you can
reach small training errors whether you
can characterize local minima and not
just global minima. So let me sort of
without going into some mathematical
details because these are sort of long
papers long calculations try to gives
give you the gist of this. So these
arguments were done a couple of years
ago later than the other other parts of
the puzzle and this uh there are other
papers also but the probably the most
theoretical treatment of the rigorous
treatment in this in this paper of Tim
Derek and me and others in my lab and
the idea is that now we have to
understand gradient descent right we
know or let's let's think of it uh maybe
let's let's put a picture
so what do we know we know that uh loss
landscape means I can only visualize
one-dimensional functions. We know that
the loss landscape of neural networks is
complicated. It has hills and valleys
and it has uh some this is your loss
landscape, right? So this is your
whatever J of theta. J is your uh
residual and so on. What we know is that
the global minimum
is uh given by some this guy is of the
order of epsilon. So we know that there
is a global minimum which is going to be
small but I don't know where it is.
Right? This is a very complex la loss
landscape. I don't know where it is. We
have to start somewhere. Let's say that
I start at this point here. Right? So at
best I can expect to land at a local
minimum. It could be that I can escape
it and go into a global minimum. But
this is a question mark. Right? I could
also start at a point here. Maybe I go
into a local minimum with gradient
descent. The question is can I escape
and go into a global minimum? I don't
know this right. This is this is the
hard part of neural network training
that you have no guarantees on how small
you can make the local minima or what
local minima can you reach or can you
ever reach the global minima. So this is
something that is uh still unclear.
Okay. So now let us try to understand
how this uh how this works and the
analysis is so this is gradient descent
right. So everything is gradient
descent. You can use Adam, you can use
uh stoastic gradient descent. Things
change a little bit but the simplest
treatment that we can do is of gradient
descent. By the way, I said L is my
function, not J. I change notation all
the time. So L.
Okay. So let's let's go into gradient
descent and try to unpeel it. So this is
your gradient descent, right? ETA is a
learning rate. So you have to take the
gradient of the loss function and the
loss function is not the supervised loss
for pins. It is the unsupervised loss or
the PD residual. I have forgotten the
initial and boundary conditions. I just
focus on and L2 is the easiest because
then it's a hilbert space. You can do
something uh you can write some math
here. So because if you had the L1 loss
then it would be harder to do any math.
Okay. So this is your PD residual which
is given by this expression here. And
this is what we have to understand
whether this process can actually get me
to a global minimum or not. Right?
Because if I don't get to a global
minimum and if I just sit at a local
minimum this could be easily order of
one and not order of epsilon. So what do
I do in this case? So it's difficult to
do some rigorous analysis because this
is a very nonlinear non-convex problem.
So what one can do is one can do some
approximation around minima. Okay. So
think of this uh theta0
as being uh it could even be the global
minimum right but let's say that I take
this to be my theta 0 and I am at a
point which is close to it and the
question is how many steps do I need in
order to get even to a local minimum let
alone a global minimum. Okay. So then
what I do in order to do so because I
have to compute these quantities right.
So I have to compute this uh gradient
then I have to differentiate with
respect to this gradient and so on. This
is [clears throat] quite complicated. So
what we do is we we do a tailor
expansion. We [snorts] say that this
theta 0 you can think of is a local
minimum. It could be also a starting
point but let's say it's a local
minimum.
Um sorry for the notation. I should have
used theta star or something but let's
say that it's um um this is the notation
that I am stuck with now. So I do a ta
expansion. So you can imagine that this
is a tail expansion. You have the first
derivative and you have the second
derivative which is given by a quadratic
form here. And this is some tailor
taylor expansion. Right? So this is some
integral tailor term. But this is a
first derivative this is a second
derivative and I stop. So I do a second
order expansion then uh one can rewrite
the gradient descent because remember
that in the gradient descent I I do the
tailor expansion.
So I plug this quantity uh so this is l
at theta k right. So I plug this
quantity in here. So I plug this
quantity in here.
There's quite a bit of math which if you
want to follow you can look at the paper
but it is not essential to look at the
paper and you can just get get an idea
of what is going on. So what is going on
is that my gradient descent can be
written as three terms essentially it
can be written as this u loss this
residual term this comes from the second
derivative. So this is hessen.
Hessen is the second derivative, right?
And then I have um something which
depends on the first derivative. And the
first derivative remember that this is
given by this guy here because I have
frozen everything around theta 0. So
this is the first derivative term which
I have expanded in this um let's say in
this matrix form. It's called a gram
matrix but that's just a notation. And
finally I have some sort of a bias
vector because I have to differentiate
this right. So this term comes out and
then you expand this. Now in 15 minutes
or 20 minutes I will not be able to do
this calculation. So you just have to
assume and trust that this is correct.
So this is a way of rewrite. This is
exact. Okay. There is no approximation
that is being made so far because all my
approximation is hidden in this error
term. So let me try to now. So what does
it happen? So this is my gradient
descent. The next step is given in terms
of the previous step, my initialization
perhaps or the minimum that I want to
reach and some error term. Okay. So now
let's uh go to the go to the interesting
fact here which is that I have to assume
in order to do any analysis that this
term here is small.
In other words, my my loss function. So
remember that I have expanded everything
up to second order and I'm saying that
my second order terms are small. So what
I'm saying is that my loss function is
approximately linear.
Now I need a nice color blue perhaps. So
it's approximately linear in this uh
regime here. Okay, it's approximately
linear. And this approximation is what
is called a neural tangent kernel.
A neural tangent kernel. It simply says
that to analyze your loss landscape, we
linearize it. I mean this is uh it's
valid at least around a point right
because if you take a smooth function
and you look at it very if you put a
microscope near a point at first order
it's always at leading order it's always
going to be linear. So this
linearization is what is called a neural
tangent kernel. And this is the only
tool that we have in order to understand
optimization for neuronet network or one
of the leading tools that we have to
understand optimization of neuronet
networks. So what does this tell me that
if I can drop this high order terms then
my gradient descent becomes what is
called simplified gradient descent.
Okay, there's quite a bit of calculation
in doing that but uh essentially it's
simplified gradient descent. It has a it
has a it has a matrix form right? So it
has a matrix form and it has some bias
term and the key role is played by this
matrix A this so-called gram matrix.
Okay, gram matrix is given by the
gradients with respect to your solution
at those points. And this is this neural
tangent kernel. So this is essentially
think of it as linearization.
So whenever you want to analyze
something nonlinear, you first make it
linear and then try to see what you can
get out of it and then you go into
something which is nonlinear. Now for
this guy here, I can do some explicit
calculations. It's relatively
straightforward to show that [snorts]
this guy is going to converge to a
minimum
theta star. So this is my minimum and
this minimum is going to be given in
terms of this quantity here. Okay. So it
will converge as long as this quantity
is less than one of course right then it
is going to go to zero. So it is going
to converge and so the number of steps
that you have in order to reach the
minimum the local minimum is given by
this quantity here. So it's an
exponential. So you can imagine that the
number of steps is given by some
quantity here. And it essentially
depends on this kappa. So the kappa is
the quantity that comes in because this
is a matrix right. So you can evolve
this matrix and you can you can do some
tricks to it and essentially this is
given by its condition number. So for
those who know linear algebra to invert
a matrix you need number of iterations
which is proportional to its condition
number and it's exactly the same. So
this is not unexpected that the
condition number shows up. So the number
of steps so what am I saying here? So
I'm assuming a simplified gradient
descent. So I'm saying that okay I'm
just trying to converge to a local
minimum and I'm saying that near a local
minimum my function is linear. Then even
even then the number of steps that I
need to converge to a local minimum is
proportionate to the condition number of
this gram matrix. Okay. So this is what
this uh paper essentially showed that it
characterized under certain assumptions
pretty strong assumptions the behavior
of gradient descent near a local minimum
not a global minimum but near a local
minimum. Okay. And now what we need to
do is to calculate what is this
condition number. Right. So the
condition number tells you everything
and this is where the problem is because
the condition number can be related to
what is called the hermission. Remember
that the ultimately everything has to be
related to the differential operator. We
have a differential operator here and
this is the only quantity that comes in
into the gram matrix because the bias
the right hand side goes into a bias
term. So this is the only quantity that
comes into the gram matrix this quantity
here. So what happens then is that you
can relate it to what is called uh a
square hermission. Okay. So this is the
quantity d star d star is the adjint.
So d star is the adjint
adjint of d. So whenever just think of a
matrix you know what the adjint of a
matrix is. So similarly for a
differential operator this is an
operator. So you can define similarly an
add to it. Okay. So now this is very
very interesting. Okay, there are some
details here which is uh which is not
important but morally uh this is a
finite dimensional quantity in infinite
dimensions this corresponds to the
square hermission or the square of the
differential operator not the
differential operator itself just to
give you an example if your differential
operator is the lelassian so you are
looking at minus lelassian is the
differential operator it's a self adjint
operator so which means that d star so
if d is equal to minus lelassian
D star is equal to minus lelassian. So d
star d when you apply it twice is
nothing but the lelassian squared. And
this has a name. It's called the
blassian.
So in 1D this will be the second
derivative. U prime this will be the
fourth derivative. Four derivatives.
Okay. So you can say oh what's the big
deal about having four derivatives. But
this is a killer. Trust me. Why is that?
Because the condition number does not
behave as the differential operator
because if it behave like the
differential operator that would be fine
but it behaves like the square of the
differential operator and this is going
to be ill condition. Uh let me just give
you some example but before the example
let me tell you what I have done because
I was on purpose a bit quick because
there's no way I can sort of compress
this information any more slowly. So
remember objective was to characterize
gradient descent with physics informed
machine learning or physics informed
neural networks. What we did is we stood
near a star sorry we stood near a local
minimum and we wanted to linearize
around something and see whether we can
approach the local minimum and we
discovered that this can be done but the
number of steps and this is important
scales in terms of the condition number.
Okay. But the condition number is of
what? The condition number is of the
hermission square of the differential
operator. If there was no differential
operator, this condition number would be
of the order of one. This would be
supervised learning. But the difference
between supervised learning and physics
informed learning is precisely the fact
that the condition number of this matrix
that characterizes the number of steps
in gradient descent is scaled in terms
of this operator here. because otherwise
it should be just identity and identity
has a condition number of one. Right?
This guy on the other hand will have a
potentially very high condition number.
So this is what breaks physics informed
machine learning because the number of
steps that you need to optimize is going
to be given in terms of the of this
condition number and this is going to be
as you'll see a very very large
quantity. How large? Here is an example.
So this is just the simplest possible
OD. It's not even a PD. It's the
simplest possible OD. It is a llashian
but with uh sinosidal right hand side
and I can take zero uh boundary
conditions. Okay very very simple. We
know what the solution is. U of X is sin
of KX
right because when you differentiate it
once you get sine of K okay 0 and 2 pi
so 2 pi so sine of kx right so then you
know exactly that the boundary
conditions are always satisfied when you
differentiate once you get a k and when
you differentiate twice you get a minus
k^ 2 so this is uh as simple as it gets
so when we try to approximate it we want
to calculate what the condition number
is going to
The condition number now is the
difference between the So what is the
condition number? K kapa is the
difference between or the scaling
between the maximum and the minimum
value and this you can analytically
calculate because this is going to be
kappa is going to be of the order of k
to the^ 4th and you can see that okay so
essentially the condition number it
grows like a fourth power
okay as the number of features as the
number of fia features in this case is
just k as k increases so if k is goes
from 10 to 100. This increases from
10,000 to 100 million. Right? So this is
uh so this is the the curse of this. You
you increase it by one order and this
increases by four orders. So what does
it mean? So now let's assume that uh my
my analysis was correct and uh I looked
at the number of steps. Remember the
number of steps is proportional to the
condition number. So if I only had uh 10
frequencies, then it would require
10,000 steps. If I had one frequency, it
would require one step, right? So if I
want to approximate sine of X, this is
straightforward. Pins should be easily
able to do that and they do it. No
problems, right? But if I wanted to
approximate 10 frequencies, this becomes
10,000. The number of steps becomes
10,000. And if I want to approximate 100
frequencies, you're out of business
because then what happens is that this
is 100 million means we have to we have
to wait with gradient descent forever,
right? So there's no way this is going
to work. And you actually see evidence
of that through the loss functions here.
So let's see. So number of FIA features
is essentially K. So this is K. So when
k equals 5 this is uh the number of
steps is now going to be 5 ^ 4 625 which
is not so bad and you can see that with
200 steps you are getting 200 epochs
you're getting good results uh but as
the and this is okay here right but as
soon as the number of steps increases
like if it goes to 95 then the loss is
of the order of a thousand so here so
this is like in this regime the the loss
is very very very badly behaved, right?
And uh even with 200 steps for this
simple one-dimensional problem, you
cannot use pins. Okay, this is uh you
cannot use this kind of an approximation
because it really is very very badly
behaved. Uh and there is some further
evidence to that. There is some
preconditioning but we will come to that
later. What is this again? The same same
behavior. This is a different
architecture. Maybe this is a
distribution of the igen values. Yeah,
because uh you know this is not
completely linear but uh there are there
a lot of zero igon values. So in
principle the condition number is
infinity. So in this case what you look
at is not the zero igon values for the
leading nonzero value and again the the
spread is quite large. Okay. So it's
still a very small value. So you have a
large condition number 60 for for this
particular example and the loss does not
really converge. So even for this very
very simple problem you know pins uh we
we thought of them as being very very
easy in some sense you can you can run
it but there is a problem you cannot
really expect to the number of steps is
going to behave very very badly and this
is in the beginning it was unexpected
certainly to me I thought that okay we
can get the training error down and then
everything else the math works but then
this is the this is the fundamental flaw
let me give you more examples so that
you are convinced So this is the
adection equation.
So now it's of course time dependent and
so on. But now it has a first
derivative. So the d star d has a second
derivative. So it is like uxx something
like this. The second derivative is a
square. Right? So the the it grows like
beta squared. So the condition number
kappa of beta goes like beta squared.
And you see that behavior. You see that
when it goes from I don't know. So it's
30 here. So it goes from 10 to 30. So
this is your beta. So 10 to 30 is a
factor of three. But the it rises quite
a lot. It goes from very small quantity
and it rises quite a lot. So it behaves
equally badly and as soon as you take
large values of your adction velocity
then you are you're stuck here. You know
the loss is simply not going down. And
other people had discovered this. You
know the other people like some people
from Berkeley and so on some years back
they had discovered this effect but
there was no clear understanding of they
they sort of related it to spectral bias
and so on but it has to do with the fact
that the problem itself is ill
conditioned it is uh everything else is
uh redundant here and you see that right
so if you this is the exact solution
[snorts]
forget about this preconditioning I'll
come to that in the next lecture but uh
so you see that there is This is the
exact solution as a function of space
and time. And what the pins do is that
in the beginning they can approximate
the solution but soon afterwards they
just they can't they totally fail. Okay.
So this is sort of the approximation
they totally fail. So if I were to
summarize I think I wanted to do more
but we are running out of time. So I
will I'll probably stop here. I want to
summarize. Uh so essentially what we did
maybe I I write a quick summary here and
we will we will sort of take the topic
for 15 minutes in the next lecture. So
let's uh do the topic. So what is the
summary today?
It's a summary.
So if you take an abstract PD T of U= F
right [snorts]
then we can show the following estimate
that the total error E so U minus U
theta
is behaving like some constant which
depends on the PDE
uh times the training error plus another
constant C quad times the number of
quadr points. So this is what we show
right. So if training error is small,
CPD and C quad
are behaving like order of one and n is
large then
pins have small error
and this is the regime that they will
work very very well. Right? So this is
good but the bad thing is
if uh this guy is large
then
this can diverge this can be large. So
this is a failure mode and more
importantly if this guy is large
then also the error is going to be large
right
and uh then we are characterized so by
using some analysis. So gradient descent
let me change this implies that
uh small et
you need number of steps
number of steps
is proportional to the condition number
of d star d
and this is very large in general right
because if you take a differential
operator it has two derivatives then
it's uh d star d has four derivatives
and this condition number behaves very
very badly. So then you cannot ensure
that number of steps become very very
large. So this is the mode that is going
to be most frequent. So as soon as you
have some interesting behavior in the
problem, either of these two modes will
kill you essentially. And this is what
even for simple PDs where the CPD is
well behaved as long as your solution is
a little bit more complicated. It has
some fast scales or it is multiscale, it
has many frequencies, then you are
you're screwed in some sense because the
condition number of this matrix grows
very or this operator grows very very
rapidly. So essentially what we are
trying to say is that as it stands pins
are not going to work okay and uh
because there are just too many failure
modes. There are some corrections. There
are some corrective remedial mechanisms
which we are going to explore in the
next lecture. But this is a very very
pessimistic story. But this is how it is
right means algorithm. It's very
promising in some sense. It's very easy.
But when you do the math, it just
doesn't add up. And this is increasingly
the realization in the community that uh
if you take complex problems then pins
cannot handle them. Okay. But in the
next lecture let's see if you can remedy
this and what are the possible
mechanisms but uh we have time for one
quick question. I know that I was a bit
quick but um you know I have a lot of
ground to cover and the important thing
is to tell you what is the mechanism and
not how it works right means this is
this was my objective but I have time
for one quick question if someone has uh
a question no
you can also ask me in the chat or you
can ask me at the beginning of the next
lecture and then we can we can take it
forward but essentially this analysis
actually tells us quite a lot about pins
that uh Just doing numerical experiments
will never tell us. Okay. Okay. Well, if
that's not the case, uh let's uh finish
today's lecture and we meet next week.
Bye-bye.